how do you learn a subject or skill in
half the time let's do this together I
want you to right now think of a subject
or skill that you just want to learn
fast you want to learn it rapidly at an
accelerated rate you want to learn
faster so you can achieve faster I want
you to remember four letters f-a-s-t you
want to forget what you already know
about the subject so you can learn
something brand new often a lot of
people don't learn faster because they
feel like their cup is full and they
feel like they know it already so always
remember to start with The Beginner's
mind I would also say forget about
what's going on in the world and
anything that's not urgent important in
your world because if you try to think
about things that are going on and be
present you can't do that and you're
only using a fraction of your own
potential if you're distracted I would
also say forget about your limitations
because you don't know what you don't
know hey it's Evan Carl Michael and I
make these videos because of my first
business I struggle to stay afloat I
quitted my business partner and the
thing that kept me going was studying
the stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn some
powerful ways to learn fast
and
joy
we're taught a lie a lie that somehow
your intelligence your memory your
learning is somehow fixed like your shoe
size but we know that your learning is
absolutely Limitless so set your
limitations aside and forget about them
the A and fast stands for active what do
I mean by active if you feel overloaded
with too much to learn and too little
time like do you have books on your
shelf you haven't read yet you get more
than 10 emails a day you listen to
podcasts there's so much information out
there but if you feel like you're
stressed like you can't keep up here's
the thing it's not your fault you know
why is because we all grew up with the
20th century education that prepared us
for a 20th century World which at the
turn of the century was working in
factories and Farms but now we live in
an age of autonomous electric cars and
spaceships that are going to Mars but
our vehicle Choice when it comes to
learning is like a horse and buggy and
one of the challenges our school has
trained us to be very passive sit
quietly by yourself be lectured to just
consume information but your brain
doesn't learn based on consumption it
learns through creation and so learning
is not a spectator sport you have to get
all you have to take great notes you
have to ask lots of questions there's so
many things you could do to be more
active the s in fast stands for State
what do I mean by state I mean the
current mood of your mind and your body
because here's the key to a better
memory information combined with emotion
becomes a long-term memory information
combined with emotion becomes a
long-term memory what do I mean by that
is there a song or a fragrance or a food
that could take you back to when you're
a child of course because information
combined with that emotion becomes a
long-term memory the challenge back in
school is what was the driving emotion
you had back in school for most people
that are bored right and a few times
anything by zero what do you get you get
zero so most people don't remember what
they learned back in school because of
the state remember this all learning is
State dependent all learning is State
dependent that if you want to learn more
control your estate now who's in control
of your state you are because you are a
thermostat you're not a thermometer what
do I mean by that what does a
thermometer do a thermometer react tax
the environment it reflects what the
environment is giving it and so we are
all thermometers at some point and that
affects our state right we react to the
weather we react to the economy react
how people treat us but in reality
where's the locus of focus who has a
control you do because you're a
thermostat a thermostat is different
right a thermostat sets a vision it sets
a goal it sets standard and what happens
to the environment the environment
raises to meet that thermostat and for
you you want to identify with the
thermostat and the most important thing
that you want to have control over is
how you feel I remember recently I got
to introduce two of my superheroes
together I talk about superheroes
because I grew up with learning
challenges from a brain injury I taught
myself how to read it took me three
years longer to learn how to read I
taught myself how to read by reading
comic books late at night something
about the superhero story really brought
it to life for me and recently I got to
introduce two my superheroes together it
was Sir Richard Branson and Stan Lee
Stan Lee not Stanley Stan Lee the
co-creators of Spider-Man Avengers X-Men
Fantastic Four and I remember asking
Stan Lee I said Stan who's your favorite
superhero and he says Iron Man he says
Jim who's your favorite superhero and he
had this Spider-Man tie I posted on
Instagram and I was like Spider-Man and
without a pause he went with great power
comes great responsibility but great
power comes very responsibility you've
heard that right and I went to him I
said Stan you're right with great power
comes great responsibility and the
opposite is also true with great
responsibility comes great power when we
take responsibility for something we
have great power to make it better and I
think the most important responsibility
we have is controlling how we feel how
do you get into that state of curiosity
of excitement I mean that who are the
fastest Learners on the planet their
children right children have this Wonder
one of my favorite quotes is from Rumi
says trade your cleverness for
bewilderman trade your cleverness for
bewilderment and finally the T and fast
if you want to learn any subject or
skill faster learn it as if you're going
to teach it to somebody else because
when you're learning it to teach it then
you're going to pay attention
differently then you're going to make it
your own then you're going to remember
it differently because here's the thing
when you teach something you get to
learn it twice rule number two is have a
goal with Brendan burchard you want to
accelerate learning here it is
goals deadlines deliverables
I know that's so basic that's personal
development 101 just most people have
never applied it to learning
if I want to learn and you know some
some of you know I've done this in so
many different areas of my life because
you've been with me for a long time and
my journey but let's I'll go back before
most of you knew me in in high school I
want to learn French
okay you can just show up to French
class once a week or three times a week
and just consume but unless it changes
when you say my goal is to learn
conversational French because I'm going
to Paris
in you know in four months
so in that four months I want to be able
to introduce myself ask where a
restaurant is ask where a bathroom is
get around town and visit these specific
places and ask for clarification and ask
people if they speak English and ask
where I should go
now I got a structure don't I
to learn French
is a philosopher is is the philosophy
level
to learn French at this level is the
science this is the science of learning
you've got to get more clear about your
learning goals what do you want to learn
specifically
by when
and what is it that you can do the
output or the deliverable that shows
that you learned it
without these three things detailed you
are learning slow
and this is what most people do you know
I like to learn about this thing they
buy five books on Amazon one of which
they read they spend one random weekend
downloading a TED talk or you know
getting sucked into YouTube but there
was no goal there's no this is the
architecture of learning would you write
that down this is the architecture
this is the this is the foundation
without this you are just browsing
let me say that again without this you
are browsing you're not learning
real learning requires this first and
foremost
write this out without goals deadlines
and deliverables you are browsing you
are not learning
and that's why most people are
struggling they're only browsing
they're only browsing they're only
reacting they live a life of browsing
reacting browsing reacting browsing
reacting without that goal without that
strive that thing to go for we're just
gonna Meander forever
but we can't Advance learning if we're
Meandering listen you learn a lot by
wandering I'm a very I love curiosity I
love walking around but remember I
promised this was a session about
Advanced learning this is not just about
General conception and just like hoping
to be inspired Advanced learning
requires a goal a deadline to
deliverable next up all right
if you really want to accelerate it
you've got to make the practice every
day or at least every week
I always tell people if you're trying to
learn something every day
when I was trying to learn online
marketing every day I was studying a
course
every day I was watching a video I mean
like every day for I would say three
years
I was taking some online marketing
course for three years every day
I want you every day
in that three years
I went from broke literally in in the
verge of bankruptcy
to earning at that end of that third
year I'd made over four million dollars
broke never did an online marketing
never set up a web page never shot a
video never sent an email didn't know
how to do any of that three years every
day
studying online marketing three years
every day
but also what I was doing I was part of
a community
I hired a mentor by basically taking
their course and signing up for their
coaching program and I just stayed in it
and every day I studied every day
and I think many of you you could have
gotten you know similar or better
results in a shorter amount of time it
took me three years every day until I
finally was like I think I really get
this
three years every day before I head like
that yeah I think I really get this all
right
I didn't struggle with the esteem part I
always said I can figure this out but I
know about myself it takes me a little
longer to learn than the average person
and I don't get discouraged I just go
okay I understand that about myself but
if I want to advance it you can't Dabble
you must immerse yourself you must get
committed you must invest in yourself
you must dive in and make it part of
your life
I did that in every area from finances
to health to relationships to running a
business all of those things I learned
that's why you all know every single day
I read for at least an hour I tend to
have about two and a half hours of block
time a day for learning
and that learning might be a call to ask
and interview somebody that learning
might be reading something that learning
might be something uh and this is
outside my normal job right this is
calling asking interviewing researching
reading just absolutely every day to
this day including Saturdays and Sundays
learning is a part of my life
and I don't say that makes me uh fancy
it just I just know I need that much
that's my stop maybe some of you can do
it once a week because you're smart and
it's easier for you to go like Hey
Brother
you know I do I know people who can
learn four or five times faster than me
just natively it's just a personal
individual intelligence they have that
can really absorb their memories better
than mine you know I've had two brain
injuries my memory sucks so I gotta I
gotta hear it a couple times for me to
really break through everyone's got
their different things so this is again
not a braggadocious session it's like it
took me three years every day
right but I stuck with it I was okay
being uncomfortable but most importantly
I was real with the fact of this ladder
okay I understand what I'm good at let
me amplify that and let me push myself
outside let me get around to more
demanding
goals more demanding community and
environment let me keep believing in
myself knowing that I can do it cheering
myself on getting around people who are
also in positive esteem Positive Vibes
to keep me encouraged and let me always
stay focused on the goal be of impact
Brennan serve others rule number three
is perform repetitions with Andrew
huberman so now I want to talk about
realistic expectations
somewhere
in Hollywood presumably it got embedded
in somebody's mind that instant skill
acquisition was possible that you could
take a particular pill or you could
touch a particular object or you could
have a wand wave over you and you would
suddenly have a skill
and so that is the result of Hollywood
at all
it doesn't exist
at least not in reality and I love
movies but it simply doesn't exist
then the self-help literature
created another rule called the 10 000
hours rule
and frankly that doesn't really match
the literature at least the scientific
literature either
I like it because it implies that
learning takes time which is more
accurate than the Hollywood at all
instant skill acquisition rule which
isn't really a rule it's a myth
but the 10 000 hours rule overlooks
something crucial which is that it's not
about
hours it's about repetitions now of
course there's a relationship between
time and repetitions but there are some
beautiful experiments that point to the
fact
that by simple adjustment
of what you are focused on as you
attempt to learn a new skill
you can adjust the number of repetitions
that you do you adjust your motivation
for Learning and you can vastly
accelerate learning
some of you may recognize this by its
internet name which is not a scientific
term which is the Super Mario effect
there's actually a quite good video on
YouTube describing the Super Mario
effect I think it was a YouTuber who has
a I think a background in science and he
did an interesting experiment and I'll
talk about his experiment first and then
I will talk about the neurobiology that
supports the result that he got
the Super Mario effect
relates to the game Super Mario Brothers
but you'll see why at the end but
basically what they did was they had 50
000 subjects which is a enormous number
of subjects
learn a program essentially taking words
from a computer program or the commands
for a computer program that were kind of
clustered in a column on the right
so these are the sorts of things that
computer programmers will be familiar
with but other people won't
and those commands are essentially they
essentially translate to things like you
know go forward and then if it's a
right-hand turn in the Maze then go
right and uh continue until you hit a
choice Point Etc so it's a bunch of
instructions but the job of the subjects
in these experiments were to organize
those instructions in a particular way
that would allow a little cursor to move
through the maze successfully okay so
basically the goal was or at least what
the subjects were told is that anyone
can learn to computer program
and if somebody can just organize the
instructions in the right way then they
can program this little cursor to move
through a maze very simple
and yet if you don't have any background
in computer programming or even if you
do it takes some skill you have to know
what commands to give in what particular
order and they made that very easy you
could just assemble them in a list over
onto the right
so people started doing this now there
were two groups
and some one half of the subjects
if they got it wrong
meaning they entered a command and the
cursor would move and
it was the wrong command
for this little cursor to move through
the maze
they saw a signal jump up on their
screen that said
that did not work please try again
that's it if they got they put in the
wrong command or it was in the wrong
sequences say that did not work please
try again and then the people would the
subjects would reorganize the
instructions and then the little cursor
would continue and if they got it wrong
again it would say that did not work
please try again okay the other half of
the subjects
if they got something wrong we're told
you just lost five points please
continue
so that's the only difference in the
feedback that they got
now I have to confess I would have
predicted based on my knowledge of
dopamine circuitry and reward
contingency and
epinephrine and stress and motivated
learning and this other thing that we've
been told in many many books on
behavioral economics and in the
self-help literature which is that
people will work much harder to prevent
losing something than they will to gain
something that you hear all the time and
it turns out that that's not at all what
happened
if they looked at the success rate of
the subjects what they found was that
the subjects that were told that did not
work please try again had a 68 success
rate
68 of them went on to successfully
program this cursor moving through the
maze
whereas the ones that were told you lost
five points had a 52 percent success
rate which is a significant difference
but the source of the success or the
lack of success is really interesting
the subjects that we're told that did
not work please try again
tried many many more times per unit time
in other words they made more attempts
at programming this thing to allow this
person to move through the maze whereas
the people that were told you lost five
points gave up earlier or gave up
entirely okay so let's just step back
from this because to me this was very
surprising
it violates a lot of things that I had
heard in the kind of popular
culture or the self-help literature that
people will work much harder to avoid
losing something than they will to gain
something and it didn't really fit with
what I understood about reward
contingencies and dopamine
but it did fit well with another set of
experiments that I'm very familiar with
from the Neuroscience literature and
I'll give you the punch line first and
then we're going to take what these data
mean and we're going to talk about a
learning protocol that you can use that
will allow you to learn skills Faster by
willingly
participating in more repetitions of the
skill learning meaning you will want to
do more repetitions even if you're
getting it wrong some or most of the
time
so the experiment that I want to tell
you about is called the tube test and
this is generally done in mice although
it's sometimes been done in rats and it
has a lot of parallels to some things
that you've probably
seen and experienced even in human life
in regular life maybe even in your life
so here's the experiment you take two
rats you put them in a tube or two mice
you put them in a tube and mice and rats
they don't like to share the same tube
so what they'll do is they'll start
pushing each other back and forth back
and forth
sooner or later one of the rats or mice
pushes the other one out the one that
got pushed out is the loser the one that
gets the tube is the winner
okay now you take the winner
you give it a new competitor
and what you find is that the mouse or
rat that won previously
has a much higher than chance
probability of winning the second time
in other words winning before
leads to winning again and the reverse
is also true if you take the loser and
you put that loser in with another mouse
fresh Mouse new mouse
the loser typically will lose at much
greater probability than chance and this
is not related to differences in
strength or size or testosterone or any
other of the things that might leap to
mind as explanations for this because
those were all controlled for
now that results have been known about
for decades but three years ago there
was a paper published in the journal
science phenomenal Journal it's one of
the three Apex journals
that examined the brain area that's
involved in this turns out it's a
particular area of the frontal cortex
for those of you that want to know and
they did a simple experiment where they
The experimenters increased or decreased
the activity of this brain area in the
prefrontal cortex little sub-region of
the prefrontal cortex and what they
found is if they stimulated this brain
area
a mouse or rat regardless of whether or
not it had been a winner or loser before
became a winner every single time
and they showed that if they blocked the
activity of this brain area
regardless of whether or not the mouse
rat had been a winner or a loser it
became a loser every single time and
this translated to other scenarios other
competitive scenarios
where they put a bunch of Miser rats in
a kind of cool chamber they'd have a
little heat lamp in the corner and mice
like heat and there was only enough
space for one Mouse to get the be under
the Heat and the one that had won in the
tube test or they had the brain area
stimulated always got the nice warm spot
okay so what is this magic brain area
what is it doing well the reason I'm
bringing this up today and the reason
I'm bringing it up on the heels of the
Super Mario effect is that stimulation
of this brain area had a very simple
and very important effect which was it
led to more forward steps more
repetitions more effort but not in terms
of sheer might and will not digging
deeper just more repetitions per unit
time and the losers had fewer
repetitions per unit time so the Super
Mario effect this online experiment and
the tube test which has been done by
various labs and repeated again and
again point to a simple but very
important rule which is neither the ten
thousand hours rule nor the magic wand
Hollywood version of learning but rather
the neurobiological explanation for
learning a skill is you want to perform
as many repetitions per unit time as you
possibly can
at least when you're first trying to
learn a skill I want to repeat that you
want to perform as many repetitions as
you possibly can at least when you're
first trying to learn a skill
now that might sound like a duh it's
just more reps but it's not so obvious
there's no reason why more repetitions
should necessarily lead to faster
learning
because you could also say well more
repetitions you can make more errors and
those errors would lead to poor
performance like misstepping a number of
times and in these cases there's there's
very little feedback right it's not like
every time uh the the wrap pushes
forward or moves back that it is sensing
oh I'm winning I'm losing I'm winning
I'm losing on a micro level it probably
does that as it starts to push the other
one out the rat or Mouse probably thinks
I'm winning and as it's backing up it's
probably things I'm losing
as you play the game the Super Mario
game
you are told nope that didn't work nope
that didn't work please try again
but the important thing is that the
winners are always generating more
repetitions per unit time it's just a
repeat of performance repeat of
performance even if there are errors and
that points to something vitally
important which is
reps are important but making error reps
is also important also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is get excited
about learning with Tom bilyu I know a
lot of people out there if you're new to
the building your knowledge game one of
the things you're struggling with is
reading a lot but not making progress so
one of a couple things could be true
first of all if you're reading things
that don't matter to you then odds are
that it's not sticking and so you want
to make sure that you're reading in
topics where you have a goal associated
with that topic So reading that thing
really matters to you that is one of the
most important things you can do is get
a hyper amount of clarity around what
your goals are so you know exactly what
books you need to be reading in order to
bolster your skill set so that you can
move forward most people lack the
clarity and because they lack the
clarity they're not reading they're not
excited about the things they're reading
and when you're not excited about the
information that you're in taking then
forget it it's never going to stick the
next thing is if you're not progressing
I promise a big part of this is you're
not deploying what you learn
most people are afraid of embarrassing
themselves stop immediately stop
worrying about embarrassing yourself it
doesn't matter what matters is on a long
enough timeline you can be anyone at
anything if you're willing to go and
[ __ ] up but most people are so afraid to
make mistakes they're so afraid of
looking stupid that they're paralyzed
they're indecisive they won't move I
make mistakes all the time and it's
embarrassing and it still sucks it's not
fun but what I know is that I will get
better and people may laugh at me in the
short term but they all give up they all
give up everyone stops everyone quits
everyone quits whenever I encounter
somebody and they are wasting time
making fun of me the one thing I know
that is gonna quit
because if you've got energy
to waste time making fun of somebody
your priorities are so Fubar you are
trying to self-soothe yourself from
feeling like an idiot by making fun of
me
so I don't waste time on what somebody
like that thinks because I know that
skills have utility if I can re I have
this goal I have massive amounts of
clarity about what my goal is I'm
reading this thing
not because I'm going to check a box
but because I'm going to turn potential
into usable skill set which is going to
let me do something which allows me to
outperform other people but it requires
that I deploy it it requires that I use
the things that I'm learning so that I
can make them concrete my own mind so
that they become a skill rather than an
idea
don't collect ideas collect skills push
yourself figure out how you deploy all
this stuff how do I actually use this in
my real life what is it good for if it's
not good for anything you're not going
to have the energy to keep learning
about it and you're not going to make
the progress that you want so make sure
I got my goal I care about this thing
I'm reading this not to check a box I'm
reading this to get good at something
and then I'm deploying it to make sure
that it sticks so that I'm making
progress and I don't care if in the
moment
I make a mistake I don't care if in the
moment I fail I don't care if in the
moment other people think I'm ridiculous
I don't care if they think I'm stupid
because I am acquiring knowledge and
knowledge stacks
knowledge stacks
you get good at this thing it allows you
to understand this thing which allows
you to understand that thing which
allows you to understand that thing and
each one of those things is minor unto
itself
but just like a Lego piece by itself is
not very interesting you can build
virtually anything you want with Legos
you have to be willing to take the time
to put them together and have people
look at the incomplete thing and say
that that doesn't make sense I don't see
it I don't understand what that is
that's going to take too long why are
you doing that Legos are stupid
but when Legos are knowledge
it will change your life
but you've got to be willing to deploy
it
so
don't waste time lamenting your
stupidity your
frustration and being slower than other
people it just is what it is Focus all
of your time and energy I have a goal
that goal makes demands those demands
require that I get better at something
that I'm not currently good at
and I'm going to read about it and then
use it
because it is only in the using that I
will make progress
so if you do that if you follow that
formula learn in the morning
use in the afternoon not research for
six months and then try learn in the
morning use in the afternoon or learn
during breakfast and use immediately
after breakfast the faster you can begin
using the things that you're learning
the faster you will make progress and
remember progress is iterative it's not
overnight you go from nowhere to
somewhere you go from one step to the
next step to The Next Step One Foot In
Front of the other and you make these
tiny little incremental bits of progress
with every new thing that you deploy
after learning but if you don't deploy
it if you don't use it one it's not even
going to stick because a lot of these
ideas are just going to go in one ear
and out the other you're really only
going to retain what hits you
emotionally and what you use and if you
wanted to hit you emotionally there
better be a goal driving you to read
that thing when you read something I
remember one time I was on an airplane
this was the craziest ever I was reading
the book Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon
Hill
and I'm going through the book and he's
talking about how uh hey there's a
secret to this book and I'm going to
give you that secret to the book
and I'm oh my God Think and Grow Rich I
want to grow Rich this is amazing I'm
broke at the time so I'm reading reading
and reading and every page is like I'm
telling you the secret I'm telling you
the secret I'm telling you the secret
and I'm like what and about I don't know
page 52 in he's like I've told you the
secret to this book on every single page
without fail and if you don't yet know
what it is you're in trouble
and I was like
what has he said on every page
and I was on an airplane
and I remember it finally dawned on me
the only thing that he had said on every
single page was if you believe you can
you can and if you believe you can't you
can't
and I was like
holy sh I got Goosebumps all over my
body I remember I looked up and looked
around the plane because it it
transformed me as a human being you can
draw a line in the sand me before
realizing that piece of information me
after realizing that piece of
information and it felt it rocked me so
hard some weird part of my subconscious
was like surely other people just felt
that and I looked around to see if
anybody else was feeling what I was
feeling of course they weren't because
all I was the only one reading the book
but that's how hard it hit me
and when you have an emotional reaction
on something like that you remember it
but you've got to want that information
so badly I was so desperate at that time
to get rich that I was like oh my God I
need to understand what's going on in
this book I was desperate for that
information and when it hit me when I
learned the thing that that book was
trying to teach me it rocked me to the
degree that I remember to this day where
I was sitting what it felt like when I
realized that thing and I will never
forget the lesson if you believe you can
you can if you if you think you can you
can if you think you can't you can't
just facts so understand that you have
to have a goal there has to be a reason
in order for that thing that you're
learning to hit you emotionally and then
you're way more likely to remember it
deploy it deploy it with immediacy and
aggression don't be afraid to fail or
look stupid because no matter how dumb
you look in the moment knowledge stacks
and a long enough timeline you can beat
anyone at anything it's literally true
but it's so directionally correct you
should live your life as if rule number
five is read write and think with Jordan
Peterson do you have any guidance around
taking notes from books and lectures
yeah yeah no problem
like don't be taking notes during the
lecture exactly because then you're not
listening to the lecture it's like
listen to the lecture and then take
notes afterwards now that doesn't work
for every discipline but but it
certainly works for disciplines like
students in my lectures I always tell
them don't
take notes during the lecture listen to
the damn lecture you can take notes
afterwards because what that does is
force you to practice remembering
and then with regards to books it's like
read
don't highlight don't underline like
that I think that that's just rubbish I
think it's pseudo work read a couple of
paragraphs or maybe an essay something
like that depending on the density of
the book close the book think about it
write down what you're thinking write
down what you remember but but but in
the context of what you're thinking
about because that instantiates it into
your memory and give and puts it at hand
like people ask me for example how it is
that I can remember all the things that
I talk about extemporaneously when I'm
lecturing and the reason for that is
because I've thought them through you
know I read them and I think oh okay
well that's an interesting idea
how does it relate to all these other
ideas that I know like what is its
significance for this idea and what's
its significance for this idea and do I
believe it and how might I criticize it
so it's kind of like I'm I'm attaching
little memory hooks to it in in five
different ways and then I've got it it's
it's part of me and that seems to be
part of recall rather than so
rather than recognition
and recall is the spontaneous Act of
remembering something complex and when
you recall something you're actually
practicing remembering it and that's
what you need to do if you want that to
be part of you so I would say
separate out the function of reading and
note taking so read think write or read
write think because the last two things
are quite similar but don't like read
the book and then read a sentence and
then write down that sentence that's not
helpful
you could read the sentence close the
book and then reformulate the sentence
so that now it's your sentence man then
you'll remember it then you'll
understand it that works really well and
rule number six the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is improve your
memory with Brian Tracy although there's
a plethora of study skills that can be
found in books or online most of these
sources will only gloss over important
content that shows you how to retain
information and study efficiently
thankfully I'm going to elaborate on
five proven strategies that can help you
maximize your retention and make your
hours of study time worthwhile so
whether you're enrolled in online
courses College grade school independent
study or studying information reserved
for an occupation you'll find these
techniques incredibly effective for your
study techniques and memory one of the
main study skills that you should focus
on is reducing the amount of
interference around you
interference is when the information
you've previously learned is interfering
with the information you're currently
learning
this means that the information you're
currently learning is having a hard time
sticking in your memory due to what
you've already studied interference is
known to cause confusion when everyone
needs to recall studied materials
sometimes it's called noise
this is due to the fact that the brain
can mix up new information that you have
previously learned to put this into
perspective let's say you went to a
business conference and met several
people then you attend another gathering
a week later and met even more people
this interference might cause you to
forget several names since your brain is
trying to process several names at once
so to avoid these issues try over
learning material
this makes it less likely for any
interference or noise to occur if you
can recall information without a pause
for thought you've overlearn information
which is the goal
another thing one can do to improve
memory is to make the information
meaningful
have the materials make sense
compare what you're learning to
something that you might be very
familiar with whether it be sports or
gaming applying what you learn to your
favorite subjects might make the
information easier and faster to digest
Four Color pens are another way to help
improve your study and keep information
organized in your brain for example
applying colored inks for a specific
study reduces interference which makes
it easier for your brain to retain
information
this is due to the fact that colored
inks inadvertently help you utilize
image-based techniques to Anchor
subjects with metal images
spacing out study is another excellent
method for retaining information and
improving study as opposed to studying a
single subject for three hours why not
study for one hour on three different
occasions with a little bit of time
management on your part learning and
retaining new information can be much
easier
concentrating too much on a single
subject can be counterproductive one
effective way to build your studying
skills is practice whole and part
learning a great way to look at this
would be combining a mix of a careful
study on specific sections and learning
everything straight through
read through materials once or twice
then separate the more complex
information to reinforce what you
already know
for long or difficult materials read
through the information quickly break up
that information into logical parts and
then review all materials from beginning
to end
one of the more effective ways to
reinforce your retention and improve
study would be reciting the materials
you're trying to memorize
reciting what you're trying to memorize
helps one avoid illusions of competence
when attempting to understand materials
this verbal repetition makes one pay
better attention to the materials
they're trying to memorize which is a
practice that was utilized by Abraham
Lincoln himself
if you can recite what you're studying
from a sentence of your materials
chances are you won't have a problem for
getting the information you're studying
lastly one of the most important methods
to improve your studying habits includes
using a study system
have a game plan When approaching new
material
and then act on it
given the several different study
methods listed above one should have no
problem memorizing materials and
achieving their goals
and one of the things that will help you
to do the work to create the things that
you want in your life
is it will help you if you train your
mind
to start spotting evidence as you're
doing the work as you're going through
your day it will help you if you train
your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed
the world is sending you positive
signals that things are going to work
out now why is it important to train
your mind to help you get what you want
well the reason why is because if you
get into a negative mindset if you start
thinking
this business is never going to work why
even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out
there look at all these idiots on hinge
why the hell should I keep doing this if
you allow your mind to start to rest in
a pessimistic negative protective scared
and doubtful stance your mind will
continue to show you reasons why there's
nobody on hinged worth talking to your
mind will continue to show you all the
reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you're never
going to lose that weight and be able to
tuck in your shirt as my friend Corinne
Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your
mind goes negative your mind starts to
scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are lining up and that makes you
in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [ __ ]
only happens like once in my lifetime
those numbers are going to line up like
that today is a really cool date let's
go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every
single freaking day of your life you
could if you train your mind and if you
start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going
to talk about so for those of you that
have read the high five habit one of the
things that I talk about a lot is every
single day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself well you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that
that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say
brain mind show me a heart today guess
what's gonna happen that damn dog
biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart
you're gonna look out at the sky and
you're gonna see a heart shape oh right
there in the mountains there's a heart
shape in the mountains in southern
Vermont you're going to see it in the
clouds what you're doing when you tell
your mind what's important to you is
you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and
allow into your consciousness
what's important to you and if you want
to see hearts by God those damn dog
treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train
your mind it's freaking incredible and
if you want to see evidence of this
follow me on social media if you follow
me Mel Robbins on social media you will
see every day I am reposting your
stories of finding heart shapes around
the world now why is this important well
it's important because it's a simple way
to prove to you that your mind changes
in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and
optimistic and encouraging of yourself
if you get serious about saying this I
don't want to see all the reasons why
I'm unhappy I don't want to see
everybody else in the world that's
launched a business or that's lost
weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and
I don't want to see that and and have my
mind process it as evidence that it's
never going gonna happen for me I want
my mind to reprogram itself and see
other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other
people in relationships and I want my
mind to say yeah if they can do it I can
do it that's evidence if that person can
get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so [ __ ] up from your past that
when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind
to filter the world differently just
like you woke up and you saw the date
today 2 22 22 and your brain saw that
was like whoa this is a once in a
lifetime day everybody
you are never going to have another day
that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your
mind already interpreted this as wow
something cool could happen
and if you tell yourself something
amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to
be looking for it I swear to God
something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
horsesh everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system
the reticular activating system I call
it the RAS I like to think about it like
a giant hair net on your head and this
Ras sits over your brain I'm probably
getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the bullsh from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there books give you access
to mentors who you would never have
access to if you are struggling thinking
I don't have connections I don't know
anybody who's had success I don't have
any good mentors everybody talks about
mentorship and how important it is and I
don't have anybody in my life to help me
books could be that for you
books can be an accumulation of of
sometimes Decades of knowledge
all condensed down into 200 300 400
pages that you get a window into
somebody else's life
and so whatever you don't know yet
whatever you want to learn chances are
it's in a book it's in videos as well I
love YouTube but it can be in books
there is no excuse not anymore for you
not to get access to the information and
be around the people
that can take you to where you want to
go I'm a big believer that you're a
product of your environment you know
think about who you're hanging out with
where you are right now where you spend
your time
what information are you feeding into
your brain the fact that you're here
watching this video is already a step up
is already showcase that you are an
achiever and that you want more out of
life that you you don't want to stay
where you are that you don't want to be
in the same spot think about one year
from today you don't want to still be
where you are right now right you want
growth you want progress you want impact
you want to touch people's lives that's
why you're here
it just needs to be more consistent it
just needs to be more thorough you know
there's a expression of the fastest way
to learn a language is to go to the
country the fastest way to learn
Japanese to go to Japan
and if you can't actually go to Japan
then you try to make your environment as
much Japanese as possible you watch
Japanese TV you read Japanese books you
go to Japanese restaurants try to order
in Japanese you start hanging out with
Japanese people you take online Japanese
classes you watch Japanese YouTube
channels like you try to be around it as
much as possible and for too many of us
we're not doing as much you know are you
consistent in watching inexpressive
videos every morning I make them every
morning for you but you're probably not
watching them every morning are you
consistent in your other habits and your
other routines in the books that you're
reading and the content you're consuming
like are you consistent enough and
that's usually the problem
is that you have these moments where
you're bold and you're ambitious and
like I'm tired of this life and I want
to do better and this is the day and so
you have the energy and motivation and
you go off and do the thing but then
tomorrow you wake up and it's just not
there anymore and you don't stay
consistent on the habit
and the only difference between the
people who've had tons of success and
and where you're at right now is that
they just kept doing it
they just stayed consistent on the habit
and so
if you look at reading as an example I
used to read a ton
before YouTube came out before videos
I'm a visual learner I'd much rather
watch something than than read it but
there was no YouTube there were no real
videos to learn from so I started with
books and now I've come back to books a
little bit where I'm I'm trying to read
10 pages a day so the goal is 10 pages a
day and I've been
95 consistent on hitting 10 pages a day
and I also like to read seven to ten
books at a time and people think that
that's crazy why seven to ten books at a
time
let me tell you why and you can see if
that's a fit for you or not
a book represents an idea
when you're reading a book you you step
into somebody else's world you step into
somebody else's skin you start to think
like them this is the point if you're if
you're reading somebody's book you start
to think like them if you're watching
somebody's video you start to think like
them that's why that habit is so
important because the more you're around
it you'll start to think like the people
you want to be like as opposed to
thinking like the people who you're
around right now
if you're around negative people you
start to think more negatively right you
don't want that you want to be the toxic
person
and so when you're reading somebody's
book or watching a video you start to
think like them
what I found was I would read one book
at a time and I would start to think
like them
and then I would move on to the next
book and then start to think like this
other person and then forgot about the
first person that I was that I really
liked you could be into the book you
could love it like wow what a great book
and then as soon as you put it down
because you're done and you pick up
another book
it starts to fade the half-life is
really short and reading the same book
over and over and over again
just loses its impact maybe you can read
it once a year but if you just pick up
the same book and then read it on repeat
it loses its impact just like watching
the same video loses its impact if you
watch it every single day every single
day every single day
so what I wanted to do was micro dose on
books
and it was an experiment so I don't know
it's going to work but I tried it and I
really liked it
so I micro dose in that I take 10 pages
a day
and it's usually between 10 and 20.
mostly depending on where the chapter
ends you know so it's at least 10 so if
a chapter ends at page nine then I'm
reading another chapter so at least 10
and usually in the 10 to 20 Page
category
and I'll read seven to ten books at a
time
and as I'm going through it what I find
is that the how long that person's Vibe
lasts is much longer
so if I'm reading Jamie Kern Lima's book
believe it great book if you haven't
checked it out yet she went from being a
waitress to being selling her company
for 1.3 billion dollars in cash not not
shares not Equity cash crazy deal
amazing woman great success story if you
haven't heard of her yet Jamie Kern Lima
so as I'm reading her book
it's about believe so that's our it's
already great but she has a she has a
different way of seeing it and she has
just such a raw vulnerable energy of
sharing all of her weaknesses and
insecurities and as I'm reading the book
I I feel like her and I feel like I want
to share more and dive deeper into my
story and she's exposing a part of me
that I haven't
discovered enough of right that's what a
good book does or good video does
and so now I'm reading her book every
seven to ten days because I'm reading
seven to ten books at a time
and what I find is I get a little bit of
Jamie if you get Jamie you know once a
week you get Jamie once a week you get
Jamie it's that little bit of a reminder
of the person that you want to be no I
don't want to be Jamie but there's
pieces of Jamie that will make me better
and I need that reminder because I could
call Jamie and ask her for advice but
we're not I'm not hopping on a weekly
call with Jamie so I get that from the
book
I like the variety of having a lot of
different books on the go at a time not
in one sitting like one sitting is just
one book at a time I like looking
forward to like oh I'm gonna I'm gonna
read that next week again so I look
forward to when it's coming up but I
think the biggest benefit of reading so
many books at a time is
just that you carry the feeling with
with you for a longer period of time not
even so much the tactics and the
strategies in any good book personal
development book especially but the vibe
the mindset the feeling
that that person is because again when
you read somebody's book you get
engrossed you become them almost you
start to think and feel like them and
you want that to last but it doesn't
last
so how do you make it last you stretch
out the book for longer periods of time
anyway it's a little hack that I do that
is worth a shot give it a shot give
yourself a small goal
five pages a day 10 pages a day 20 Pages
a day doesn't have to be sitting down
and finishing a book a day right the
people who can speed read and read a
book a day
that's crazy I I I haven't figured out
how to do that yet
um
but 10 pages a day is doable
and 10 pages a day to step into
somebody's world who you respect you
want to learn something from if you did
that consistently it'll start to change
your life if you watch videos like this
it'll start to change your life but
consistently not the one-off
consistently you know are you 95 percent
consistent on the things that will help
take you to where you want to be
that's the only thing that's missing you
got the heart you got the compassion you
got the desire to serve you've got a big
mission inside you you want to do good
you deserve to make more money it's all
of it it's all there it's just not
enough consistency in the pushing
forward to the life that you could have
the consistency in being around the
people who Force you in a loving way
to do more to think more to be more
of you
if you can make that change
even just for the next quarter for the
next 90 days that every day you read 10
pages of a book that inspires you or
every day for 90 days you watch an
expressive video or somebody else's
channel that inspires you it'll change
your life
and it'll start to set you up for the
habits you need for success
everybody knows the importance of
mentors most of us don't have the right
mentors in our life and with videos and
books you have access to the top Minds
on the planet to the most inspiring
people in the world
and if you're hanging around them on a
daily basis
you'll be a totally different person a
better person a better you still you
still you but better more proud of
yourself having a bigger impact and
making the money that you deserve for
yourself your family and your community
you wanted to be a professional baseball
player yeah right yeah but then you got
an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big leagues or did
you play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways I don't know you weren't going
to be in The Bigs for I wasn't I played
enough baseball with guys who ended up
in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost
we are like a lot we were now just
Thomas before we went on yeah you know
our professional athlete friends were
their career changes I went into a like
anybody like whatever your dream is when
the first one ends it doesn't happen
whether that be a relationship it could
be your marriage it ends it was a dream
right or a business venture or a sport I
went into a pretty good depression and
uh and how old were you at the time 21
22 and I ended up you know it's because
people always see the after like the
house or whatever houses or whatever the
material things are but I ended up bad
man I ended up depressed I ended up
moving back at home with my parents I
was living in the city I remember I was
living in this sleeping in the same bed
I grew up in with the same teddy bear
the same posters I was like going back
in time like six years on back where I
was totally unemployed and uh couldn't
find work didn't have the motivation to
get up and find a job just sort of
eating out of their fridge and laying
around all day so that's where I was
many many years ago after baseball and
when you realize things in your life
happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years later that happened for
me that was actually a good thing and so
I was unemployed I couldn't find a job
and my old man my dad was the best dad
role model he could ever have in your
life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're going to get this damn
job so show up there tomorrow morning 8
A.M ask for Tim so I walked out I drive
down there it's a place called McKinley
Home For Boys little did I know that
would alter my entire life that was the
most significant thing that happened to
me and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh dude yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go look literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like a literally McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yep all boys it's in San
Dimas here and wow it just altered my
life man because I I'd been an athlete
had a huge ego had that mask I wanted to
compete I wanted to win I wanted
attention I wanted recognition first
time literally in my life I went well I
I love helping people I love making a
difference and my boys were just come
from horrendous situations and so just I
always say this all the time and I have
those eyes too you have them I think
sometimes kids who grow up with some
dysfunction they just have different
eyes yeah they just have these eyes that
are these boys all were different but
they had that same eyes they're just
like man love me believe in me you know
care about me and I had those eyes
because I grew up in an alcoholic family
and my whole life changed I just went
wow I love I actually love helping
people and being involved in people's
lives I didn't know that because
everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an
athlete right everything's about you
you're amazing free dinners free this
you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about
me it was about these 10 boys that ended
up being 10 of them and it just altered
my life man and so after that I ran into
the financial business that I ended up
in but I would have completely flunked
out of that Financial business had I not
been with my boys for those years and I
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I
think about I'm not kidding you I think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where I
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what I wanted to do I always wanted
to be famous and Rich and successful and
now I just wanted to serve yeah I wanted
to help the little did I find out I
could get rich and famous and all that
other stuff I thought I wanted through
serving people well to me a breakthrough
is a moment in time it's a moment when
the impossible becomes possible and you
know just think about it they act upon
it you know it's like you can have a
concept that doesn't create a
breakthrough the breakthroughs and you
get to the point where you actually
gonna do something about it and I ask
people all the time I ask your listeners
or viewers as well it's like I'm sure
you've had a time where you struggle
with something right you're gonna do
something about this relationship but
you keep not changing it right you know
pulling back or you're gonna stop
smoking or you're gonna go lose those 25
pounds or whatever it is and you start
to make progress and then you pull back
and you get disappointed and get
frustrated but then there's some times
where finally you hit this threshold you
hit this moment where your brain says
not another day not in an hour I'm
changing this relationship I'm losing
this weight I'm making this happen and
people create that breakthrough and it
can be happen you know it's the
difference between what triggers it
versus what makes it possible what
triggers it is usually pain or massive
inspiration nothing in between does it
most people they hit a threshold of pain
and say it's like you know I ask people
how many of you ever been in a
relationship way too long and everybody
raises their hand they go why why just
stay you weren't happy they weren't
happy it's just because of the unknown
the uncertainties the the idea of change
it could be worse you know to be alone
but then there's that moment when you
finally hit the threshold you go it's
been painful in the past it's painful
now it's gonna be painful future I'm
gonna change it now so the trigger that
finally made that happen might ask your
audience if they think of something
where they finally broke through what
was the trigger usually that moment that
day you hit a threshold of I can't take
anymore I'm changing or
something inspired you you saw someone's
possible and they can do it I can do it
as well but that's what makes it
possible what makes it last is it
changing your emotions or changing your
belief system or a new strategy right
you and I both know because you're both
strategists the right strategy how you
can consume a book and remember more of
it in 30 or 45 minutes than you did when
you used to spend 10 days on the damn
book right you know it's the right
strategy but you're not going to find
the strategy until it's a must for you
not a [ __ ] you know what I mean or it's
that change in belief well it's like
okay I've put up with this crap long
enough I'm better than this there's
something more in me that you finally
finding yourself or you finally get
pissed off enough or you get excited
enough to make that real change and so
what I've studied is
I like to take complex things and make
them simple because I found that you
know the more you know when I was really
young I tried to make things more
complex I think to try to convince
myself how smart I was or other people I
don't know what but it's stupid because
complexity is the enemy of execution and
the only way your life changes or your
business changes is execution so it's
like how do you make it simple and I
started looking at all these you know
I've been doing this since my 45th year
doing this I started when I was two of
course and and I started seeing these
patterns all over the world working with
the greatest people on Earth athletes
business people the most challenged
people in prisons like what are the
common denominators and all these
cultures and they began to see there's
three things you need for a breakthrough
but most of us do them in reverse order
so we don't get the Breakthrough the
number one thing most people do when
they want to have a breakthrough they
don't they want to change their body
they want to change their Finance they
look for a strategy which makes common
sense that's what I used to do
but the problem is
strategy could be the problem and maybe
you need a better strategy but that's
not usually the real problem right like
for example three quarters of America is
overweight or obese if we're the fattest
humans in the history of the world we
all know covid other than age the number
one risk factor is obesity that's number
one and yet very few people do anything
about it and why is that is it because
you know the strategy for being fit and
strong is so complex or only the one
percent know it or it costs a fortune to
do it now you have to be fighting not to
see all the strategies that make your
body physically better around you
everywhere so it's you could have the
wrong strategy like I remember years ago
on the cover of Time Magazine they had
the Atkins diet and they said you know I
think it was 15 of Americans were doing
it well if you gotta pee on a stick so
you don't get too acidic and your breath
is that bad it's pretty obvious that's
not sustainable so sometimes it's a
strategy problem but we work for the how
first and you've never figured it out
your emotions get in the way
it's the wrong sequence it's like the
dog bit Johnny Johnny bit the dog same
words different experience of your
Johnny so strategy naturally is where
people go but rarely do they change with
that what the real problem usually is
the story they've developed and a story
is just code for all the things you told
yourself over and over again until you
believe them right there's an old
language pattern that says tell why big
enough loud enough long enough sooner or
later people believe it that was Hitler
said that and so most of us are Hitler
in our own mind so it's not that they
can't you know what do people say how
come I can't lose like I can't lose
weight because you know I've tried
everything no if you tried everything
you'd be fit right they didn't try
everything I've tried millions of things
really name them well I've tried Hunters
name them and then they'll tell you
three stupid things that don't work that
they did over and over again right so
it's the story I I don't have a
relationship because all the good ones
are gone or they're gay and I'm not or
I'm gay and they're not or whatever the
story is the story is what will keep you
like I'm sure you know Jim you have so
many great strategies you share with
people how do you have times when you
give someone an answer right there in
front of them and they just can't even
see it right they don't believe it
because the story is literally blinding
them in Psychology we call it a scotoma
a blind spot
but then there's one level deeper than
deeper the story
and that's your state the mental
emotional physical state you're in
because when you're in a low mental
emotional physical state
you can have all the brain capacity in
the world but you're not going to use it
and so when you're in a lousy State you
come up with a lousy story and then no
strategy works it doesn't matter what it
is if I don't know if you've ever
noticed if you ever gotten really angry
at somebody and then suddenly you
remember all the ways they've ever
screwed you over you've been upset with
them right but on the other hand you
fall in love and what's wrong with life
nothing I have no money it doesn't
matter we're in love it's all wonderful
right so this sequence on which we do
things accelerates or decelerates or
stops progress when it comes to a
breakthrough and what I found is change
the state first you you're like we you
and I can talk and give people a million
strategies but if I'm sitting here at
home in this state and I'm just
listening like this and nodding like
this yeah that makes it nothing's gonna
happen
so the reason that I've done events over
my lifetime and the reason why I do
immersion events you know 10 12 13 hours
a day you learn a little bit at a time
like language you don't remember the
language a few years later but I drop
you in Rome and say you got no teacher
and you got 60 days I'll be picking you
up I'll pick you up 60 days from now
you're going to be speaking Italian
right especially if I put you maybe with
some passionate people who are really
going for it in their life you're gonna
have a whole different state about you
you're going to develop a new story and
you're going to figure out the strategy
so I think the the challenge for most
people especially with covet
is we've all had our state dropped
people have been isolated they've been
pushed at home they've had expectations
that have fallen away like I remember a
year ago a lot of people are like all
right we got vaccines now it's a new
year it's going to be a brand new thing
you know 2021 now this year you talk
about it be learning how many goals or
anything because they've gone to learned
helplessness because they've been
disappointed so many times they start
thinking the problem's forever no
problems forever no war is forever no
pandemic is forever your mind is weak
now and it's gotten a weak habits and
you're in a lowered state so you start
to believe that and so it's like you got
to change people's State first then you
got to give them the story that can help
them they need to give them the
strategies that work in there even if
you don't give them the strategy they'll
figure out their own strategy you're a
perfect example of that right you've
figured it out because you got yourself
to the point where it's like I've got to
turn this around and then you have
something that you can give and that
expands your life as you've experienced
it you have to make it decision in your
life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them I don't think it's
unreasonable to assume that that's how
you elicit the best from them the best
that can be elicited you're going to get
hurt sometimes and betrayed but that's
going to happen no matter what approach
you take I think that's the most
effective approach and that is perhaps
the most effective approach to existence
per se to approach it with love and
courage and and so that's how that looks
to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities one of the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer you become susceptible
to thinking you have the life
I grew up in a little town in Louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
you probably hear the accent
and uh I grew up in a middle class a
middle class family my my dad died when
I was 10 years old my mother raised us
and my mother constantly told me how
proud I should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
uh every time my mom was my best friend
and every time I would have a success it
didn't matter whether I was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime I had a success
she was the first person I called I
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
people that were closest to me I called
my mom and say mom you never believe I
just bought a real estate deal I started
this company I bought my first real
estate deal it's 38 units it's four
million dollars and she'd be like that's
awesome I love you Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action it is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all is impossible try doing
it right now
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true I wouldn't put
it in the book If I rewrote it the
second level of action is
um to retreat this is what most people
do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay
I was up late whatever you came up with
whatever reason I'm gonna make the call
by the way any retreat in life any
single Retreat is a discipline and a
commitment
to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
no I'm not there
okay and I know how much I'm grinding
every day how much I'm pushing every day
how how many how many hours I put in
today what's the maximum number of hours
you can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to be outside of that moment
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x
I'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me
and the reason when I closed the book
The reason I was like ah whatever I had
figured out what I had done wrong okay I
had to embrace the the the the idea that
three or four million dollars in a bank
and a house paid for and two cars and a
marriage and I got it better than
everybody else and my mama loves me just
the way I am was all this this middle
class
this American particularly here in
America how many of you live in America
okay in America the middle class it is
the sleeping chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class dude I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
back just going to college
well because what are they manufacture
in college
they manufacture average people at
college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer when I analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back
over there on my on my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage you need
to learn how to either develop products
you need to learn some of the technology
needs that you have there's a lot of
different hats that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company is wearing that hat
right and so imagine if you're um needs
surgery but you're not a good surgeon
what would you do you'd have to find how
do I get somebody who could do the
surgery so for those of you who are not
good at marketing or sales which is the
oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done I know you all have
big goals Big Dreams big aspirations
just like I do you got Ambitions to
become an amazing person to build your
career to create contribute to give to
be an awesome human being but all of
that is impossible without great habits
set up if you don't have routine and
structure set up in a way that will keep
you on track then you'll you'll fall off
and and having new goals without new
habits is kind of like you know having a
new car without wheels you know the
habits are the wheels they are the
things that make you able to achieve the
goals so you got to have good habits but
the challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out more on a more regular basis
and then it goes away or you say you
know I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my lover and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with with this let's I
have a goal in mind let's say you want
to become more present and calm
throughout the day again you could write
that down on a journal I'm going to be
more present and calm you can meditate
in the mornings like today don't be more
present and calm and you're you could
you could start out with good intentions
but those fall apart without a trigger
moment set up throughout the day to
remind you that so what if you did this
what if you just set up on your phone
three alarms during the day with a label
that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
it you can't do it once a day you have
to have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water
put your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words so what words would you love
to have describe you as a person that
you would be happy if that was how
people described you what would those
words be have those and now set them up
in your life I teach Executives to do
this as well I have them have a door
frame trigger when they walk into their
office in the morning as soon as they
walk through that door frame they have
boom three words go through their mind
about how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
frame every time they walk into a
meeting into the conference room when
they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
think they have to completely change
their life what would change your life
completely is setting up more trigger
moments and associations that when you
see something you do this that when this
action is taken then that happens that
when you have the opportunity to set up
alarms on your phone you set them up so
that you're interrupted in your everyday
life to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know how to learn anything with
ease check out my interview right here
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you need to ask yourself if you're
in the right place a lot of us get into
life and take a path because our
families wanted us to take that path or
there was some societal expectations